so I want to talk about parenting there
was a viral Tick Tock video
caught my eye a mom made this video
showing her son her son is five years
old and her son got punished for
refusing to clean his room okay
and the punishment started a pretty
intense debate on so let's show it I'm
going to show it in full it's not very
long at all and then let's talk about it
that's her
two days in a row to clean his room
two days in a row
yeah
foreign
[Music]
okay I will do that gladly
she's throwing all the toys away
I'll read that text you in a second if
it's too hard to read because we're
going to go over that okay so this
caused a huge controversy okay one of
the biggest components of why it was so
controversial is because the kid is five
I think it's a little boy I'm not 100
sure kid is five so my first comment on
this why are there so many toys
that's too much going on okay and I know
it's hard I know like Grandma brings the
toy and Grandpa brings the toy and Aunt
Maria brings the toy and suddenly it's
just like a toy factory right I don't
allow that stuff in my house because one
it's too much stimulation for kids two
they don't play with all of it it just
winds up being a mess right that's how
it works so you gotta as a parent you
gotta say okay I have a philosophy a toy
comes in a toy goes out we donate the
toy we bring a new toy in we donate the
old toy I have Hartley has a small
section of his room for toys a small
sectional living room it doesn't look
like a toy factory I won't allow it okay
it's not necessary and it's over
stimulating for these kids remember when
we were little you know what I played
with sticks little sticks I was like oh
let me write my name in the dirt let me
wipe it let me write it again okay like
they really don't need all that stuff
going on that's number one
secondly this is for a five-year-old so
that's why it was controversial
five-year-old to me needs to be
disciplined but not to be traumatized
he's that baby's too small to go and
that room was filled with toys that's
too many toys you allowed too many toys
as a parent to go into that house you
know it and now the kid is gonna make a
mess because it's a kid he's a kid he's
gonna just make a mess and he's not
gonna know what to do it's like
overwhelming you've got to go around
that room with him and be like look
we're gonna play a game we're going to
do it together so you play and then
we're gonna have this is how you clean
up and we're gonna I'm gonna show you
and maybe there's a little reward I
don't know how you do it in your house
we do it together we do clean up time
together
you can't traumatize a five-year-old
it's very traumatizing for that kid to
have all those toys there and then
suddenly you see the toys are gone
because they bond with those toys you
know like their little stuffed animals
they're blanky their truck very very
traumatizing now let's get to the root
of what's wrong here
you see the text
this is what the text read on the screen
mama is not raising no disrespectful men
it's not a mommy's job or women's job to
do anything you make the mess clean it
up you see Mama struggling help her
don't sit there and let a woman struggle
period my babies will learn this quickly
so okay
there's some issues going on here
she's got the issues she's got issues I
don't know who it's with I don't know if
it's with a man if it's with something's
going on here that she transferred on to
that kid this suddenly became about not
just a five-year-old not cleaning his
room this became about men and women's
jobs and as disrespectful and somehow
you're making that five-year-old little
boy bear the burden of probably
disrespect that was thrown your way by a
grown ass man
let's call it what it is
you can't do that that's why I became
controversial because it became very
clear to people is my guess
that this was no longer a conversation
about a little boy cleaning his room but
went a lot deeper
than that
what do you think Tyler I mean would you
you have a look at how old is your how
was your baby my daughter's 18 months
18. she puts all her toys away I agree
with this mother 110 percent okay so now
would you do you feel like it's a little
too harsh though to like discard the
toys was that a step too far for you no
so for one I don't know I'd be surprised
if she actually threw him away maybe she
did maybe she put him in the garage or
something okay two at four years old I
was doing karate and I everything I did
was discipline yes ma'am no ma'am yes
sir no Texas down the line don't make me
talk about Texas again Tyler listen you
have to get the these kids early because
if you let them go down this path it
only gets more and more and more
ingrained and I'm not listen at five
years old I don't think that's too young
I think it may be three like no work
like you say work with your kids sit
together but at 18 months like if Aurora
pulls a book out and she reads it she
passes it back to us and we say okay now
we put it back and she goes to put it
back that's good parenting though and
you know what though you started that
early what I get the vibe from this
situation is that she let it go too far
if that's the case then that's on her
yeah it's just it seems to me like first
of all there's a lot of toys going on
there so how did it get that bad yeah
that's true you know what I'm saying how
did it get that bad you had to let it
get that or you realized when there were
half as many toys that your kid wasn't
picking them up and then you added more
to the pile what you need to do is when
you see a situation and Hartley's not a
big fan Aurora's beautiful name by the
way I think it's a Princess Aurora I
love that
um Hartley's not a big fan of picking up
the toys I'm going to be honest with you
I have to really like get him to do it
doesn't do it it naturally now he's
getting into it a little bit because
he's like oh Mommy's doing it it's cool
it's like part of the part of the play
is now putting them back
but I got I got him on track when there
weren't a lot of toys and I have a
feeling that if I had let that go and it
was just a sea of toys his little mind
would have been like I'm not doing it
you know so you got it you got to start
that discipline early so because so it
doesn't become overwhelming for you or
for them that's my take on it
and I see what she the problem is with
Tick Tock too you put these videos out I
give a lot of props to people they put
this and then people the haters come now
she's a terrible mother she's probably
not a terrible mother she probably just
got caught up in a moment took video
didn't realize you know what I'm saying
well and the other thing too is there's
no context for this it's like you said
it's like okay how long was this
happening how long was she was was there
a mess before and then she just added
more toys to it like did she throw them
away it looked like trash is that a joke
and really she just stuck him in another
room to teach him a lesson and then
showed him the toys were there so right
we can't count on context when it comes
to tick tock if you like the short clip
you can catch another one here or you
can catch the full episode right here
foreign